This is a controversial topic. You know
what? I I don't even know why, honestly.
But anytime you bring this topic up,
man, it causes anger in people. It
causes division, strife. And you know
what? I think we should be able to look
at Bible topics in a civil way. We
should be able to study each topic line
upon line and discuss with brothers and
sisters in Christ and not divide in such
a, you know, hostile way. I don't
understand why topics like this make
people think, "Oh, if you don't believe
this way, you're not even a Christian.
You're not saved." And and uh you're
going to find out one day and all this
stuff. I just want to know what the
Bible has to say. My whole life, I've
been a truth seeker. And there's been
topics that I've been taught my whole
life in church growing up that I found
out when I read God's word, they weren't
even true. that certain teachings,
certain beliefs, certain doctrines are
not even biblical that are being taught
in the majority of mainstream
Christianity. And this is one of those
topics that I want to get into. It's a
very freeing topic because the truth
will set you free. And this topic is
something that never sat well with me
until I understood it fully. It made me
understand God's character, who he truly
is. And the truth about this subject is
something that will really change
people's lives forever. If you guys have
not watched this video, go to our live
tab and watch this video first because
if you don't understand this, then this
is going to be a harder topic to
understand. Not impossible, but
definitely a little more complex. You're
going to have a lot more questions. And
it's not bad to have questions. I don't
understand when people think we
shouldn't question things, that we
shouldn't be searching for truth like
gold, that we shouldn't be always
digging in God's word and seeking for
truth. We get in this mindset that um we
must put oursel in some denominational
box. And if if we have these fundamental
beliefs, then you can't ever believe
outside of that box, even if you see it
in God's word, because I don't know,
you're you're not a part of our group or
whatever it is. I don't care about any
of that. All I want is the truth from
God's word. So definitely check out what
really happens when you die. It's gonna
make this a whole lot clearer. I want to
show this clip from these guys. The guy
in the middle is the Christian YouTuber.
None of the four other guys are
Christians. And they're throwing some
stuff at him, you know, and he's he's
pretty good at defending his faith. I
think we have some different beliefs on
on certain things, I'm pretty sure. But
what this guy says is something that
comes up all the time. Every time I can
just post John 3:16 on my social media
and some militant atheist will come out
and just start attacking you and saying,
"Oh, if if God's all loving and all
powerful, then why is there all this
chaos in the world?" And I, you know,
I'll explain that it's because God gives
us the the greatest gift of all time,
free love or free will, which is love.
and they'll be like, "Oh," and it always
comes back to, "Well, God says bow or
burn, and that's not freedom of choice."
And so, I don't believe in God, and I'll
never tr I'll never bow to God and all
this stuff. It always comes back to this
topic of, well, God burns people for
eternity, even if it's just for one
lifetime of ignorance. That's always
always 100%
comes up in debates against
Christianity. Guaranteed 100% always
comes up. So check this out.
>> We still want to we we want the
eternity. It's still begging the
question.
>> The alternative is hell. That's the
issue I have. If there was a first
class, a business class, and a coach,
I'm with it. I don't got to be first
class. That's fine. But the idea that
that is a like God doesn't owe you
heaven. He don't he don't need to give
you hell.
So his mindset and a lot of people's
mindset is look what if I go through
this whole life and I think that the
truth is Buddhism or or Muslim. I think
Allah and and I'm a good person or I'm a
newager. I'm a good person. I always try
to do things that are good but I believe
the wrong belief system.
God is going to burn you forever and
ever and ever. And this guy's like,
"Look, man. I don't have to be like
first. I don't have to be like top in in
the kingdom of heaven. I I want heaven,
but why is the alternative got to be
hell? It just sounds so harsh, you know,
burn you forever and ever and ever and a
million years goes by and it's just the
beginning of your punishment because of
your one life of ignorance. One life of
ignorance.
There's some uh nuances in there. You
know, the Bible does actually say that
in Acts it says that God winks at our
sins committed in ignorance. But once
the light of truth comes, it is our
responsibility, our duty to obey that
truth, to turn to that truth. So that
that goes with anything, idolatry, uh
the commandments, whatever it is, God is
only judging you according to the truth
that you have. But it's our
responsibility to search that truth out.
Like dig for truth like gold. It's our
responsibility. We can't choose to live
in willful ignorance. Actually the Bible
speaks contrary to that completely
against that that willful ignorance will
lead to death.
So let's look at some verses here. Um so
what is hell? Because we hear this when
you read the King James Bible or any
English translation of the Bible, you're
going to see this word hell. And
immediately you get these images in your
mind of people screaming in torment and
you know that demons are poking them
with pitchforks and it's just this
endless neverending eternal torment,
inferno, fiery furnace. But what is this
word hell? How come we see it in the
Bible so much? is is that you know this
word actually comes from four different
original translations, original words
from the original Greek, the original
Hebrew, and we're going to look at that.
But Psalm 16:10, the Psalms were written
by David, a man after God's own heart,
right? And he says, "For thou wilt not
leave my soul in hell, neither will thou
neither wilt thou suffer thine holy one
to see corruption." So, why is David
talking about he's going to be going to
hell? Why does he say, you know, I'm I'm
going to hell, but you won't leave my
soul there. This sounds like a
contradiction, right? Because he's a man
after God's own heart, and yet he's
saying he's going to hell. The Bible
doesn't contradict itself. Acts 2:27
reiterates this. Because thou wilt not
leave my soul in hell, neither wilt thou
suffer thine holy one to see corruption.
And in Acts 2:31 it says, "He seeing
this before spake of the resurrection of
Christ that his soul was not left in
hell, neither his flesh did see
corruption." So
they're explaining here in Acts that
David was writing a prophecy. David was
writing a prophecy about the coming
Messiah, which was Jesus Christ, and
that he would be resurrected out of
hell. Now, did Jesus go to hell? Woo!
That's a another topic altogether.
That's a whole different video.
I'll challenge you. Look in the Bible.
Find me where the verse, the chapter and
verse is that says that Jesus went down
to hell and he fought Satan and took the
keys to hell. I mean, there's all kinds
of things that we're being taught in
churches that are just aren't in the
Bible. And so, I don't believe that
Jesus went to hell. I don't believe
that. Now here it says that his soul
would not be left in hell. But what is
hell? That's the whole point. When we
see what looks like a contradiction in
the Bible, we have to look at all the
verses. Like because the Bible says
study line upon line, precept upon
precept, here a little, there a little
by the mouth of two or three witnesses.
Now that's four times that it's saying
don't build a doctrine out of one verse.
It has to be backed up. The Bible backs
itself up by the mouth of two or three
witnesses. Uh here a little, there a
little, even Old Testament, New
Testament, compare. Gather all the
information you can on a certain subject
and then weigh out the evidence. And if
it looks like, well, all these verses
say that when you die, um, you sleep in
the grave until the resurrection, but
here's these three strange verses that
look like when you die, you go right to
heaven. Then we need to look at that.
say, "Why do these three verses
contradict 20?" And look at the original
Greek and Hebrew. Look at the context.
See if there's Look at some of the other
translations and see what they say.
Because remember, when we're reading an
English translation, we're reading
English translated words from Hebrew and
Greek. And there's not always a good
perfect translation. And so sometimes
other translations outside the King
James Bible might have a better wording.
I am I'm King James preference. I'm not
like strict got to be King James only,
but I always recommend reading the King
James. That's me. But every once in a
while, there are certain scriptures that
seem to be translated just a little bit
better in certain phrases in other
translations. So use Bible Hub. Bible
Hub will show you all the different
translations and you might see a pattern
and say, "How come like all these are
saying this, but the King James says
this?" Um, that'll help you understand a
little more, too.
So, hell, the word that we see in the
Bible, the English translated Bible is
hell, but it's really four different
words. Shol, Hades, Gehenna, and
Tartarus. Now, what do these words mean?
We're going to look at that. Shil. The
word shil is a Hebrew word. It's the
only one out of these four that's
actually in Hebrew. And the word shiel
in the Strongs is H7585.
And it means grave. Notice here. See how
it says grave and pit. Grave and pit.
Now the word hell is here. But what is
that? What's hell? This is just showing
you other words in the Bible, other
English words that use the same words.
So this um whatever Greek or whatever
Hebrew word this is H758
H7585
sometimes the English translation said
grave 31 times actually sometimes the
English translation said hell 31 times
and then three times it it changed this
word to pit. So that's interesting.
Right
now we see shiel here's some examples um
where it talks about in Genesis 37:35 it
says and all his sons and all his
daughters rose up to comfort him but he
refused to be comforted and said for I
will go down into the grave which is
this word shiel h 7585
unto my sons mourning thus his father
wept for him. Now, this is talking about
Abraham, I think. I'm pretty sure.
Why is Abraham talking about going to
hell? He's not. He's talking about the
grave. That's why it says grave. That's
why it's translated grave. Genesis
42:38.
And he said, "My son shall not go down
with you, for his brother is dead, and
he is left alone. If mischief befall him
by the way in which he go in and the way
in which ye go, then shall ye bring down
my gray hairs with sorrows to the grave.
But this is the same word that in other
trans in other parts of the Bible is
translated hell 31 times. And Genesis
44:29 says, "And if you take this also
from me and mischief befall him, ye
shall bring down my gray hairs with
sorrow to the grave." So this word shiel
is often translated grave. It's
actually, if we look back, it's
translated grave 21 times and pit three
times, which means grave and pit
actually outnumber the times that it's
translated the word hell because it's
only translated the word hell 31 times,
but it's translated grave and pit
combined 34 times. So therefore it seems
that the weight of the evidence tells us
that shiel means grave or literally a
pit which is a grave as well. So the
weight of evidence is going towards
grave. Now this word hell we don't
really know what that is. That's just an
English word.
Um so now we're looking at Hades. So
sometimes the Greek use this word Hades
and it was translated to hell. Notice
right here it's the it's in Greek G86
and it's translated to hell 10 times in
the English and grave once in the
English. But here it's telling you the
definition. It says name Hades or Pluto
the god of the lower regions. Remember
Greek mythology, the the time period
that Jesus was walking the earth with
the disciples, there were two worldviews
going on. There was the religious
Jewish Pharisees and their traditions,
right? The Jewish traditions and there
was the Romans and the Greeks and their
paganism. So there was paganism over
here and Jewish tradition over here.
Both of them were wrong because the Jews
were adding to the law and just they
were not really
obeying God's word. They were making
legalism and adding to the law and all
these things. They didn't have a
relationship with God. So both sides
were wrong for different reasons, but
they were both wrong. And so right here
it says, this is straight from blue
letter Bible. Name Hades, which is a
Greek god, or Pluto, the god of the
lower regions. Orcus, the netherworld,
the realm of the dead. Later use of this
word, the grave, death, and hell. So
we're seeing that this word Hades is
used to mean grave as well, death and
hell. But it also is this Greek
mythological god Hades.
And here we see some examples of the use
of it. In 1 Corinthians 15:55 it says,
"Oh death, where is thy sting? Oh grave,
oh Hades, where is thy victory?" So this
isn't talking about some eternal fiery
torture chamber. It's talking about the
grave. Where is your victory? This is
after we are resurrected and we put on
immortality. And then at that moment
when we put on immortality after the
resurrection when Christ returns then
will come to pass the saying oh death
where is thy sting oh grave where is thy
victory. So this word hades means grave.
Now in revelation 20 verse3 it says and
the sea gave up the dead which were in
it and death and hell delivered up the
dead which were in them. Now, are people
in hell in a fiery eternal torture
chamber dead? Because the teaching is
that they're alive, conscious, suffering
for eternity. But right here, it says
that hell delivered up the dead which
were in it. That doesn't sound like the
eternal torture chamber, but more like a
grave. And then it says which were in
them, and they were judged, every man
according to their works. So, this is
talking about the judgment. What happens
at the judgment? Christ returns and many
that sleep in the dust of the earth will
rise from where? From their graves.
They're not coming out of an eternal
torture chamber to be judged. That
doesn't even make sense when you think
about it. Picture Cain. Cain, I'm pretty
sure we can all agree, is not going to
be in the kingdom. So, picture Cain
dies. He's the first person ever born on
earth. He's been in hell for 6,000
years. Do you think he needs a judgment?
I think he already knows his judgment.
If he's burning in hell for 6,000 years,
no judgment is needed. He's already
received his judgment. He knows when
Christ returns if he's going to come out
of the fiery pits of hell to be judged
again and thrown back in hell. It really
doesn't make any sense, right? So, even
though the translation in English says
hell right here, it makes absolutely no
sense because dead bodies aren't burning
in hell. Corpses aren't just burning in
hell. And there's no reason to deliver
them out of hell just to put them right
back in hell. Right? Hope you guys are
following.
And then Revelation 20:14 says, "And
death and hell were cast into the lake
of fire." This is the second death.
Death and hell were cast into the lake
of fire. I thought hell was the lake of
fire. So this is saying that death and
hell are going to be cast into hell.
Also doesn't make any sense, right? This
is saying death and the grave. The whole
process of humanity dying will be cast
into the lake of fire. And that's the
second death, the eternal death that
will end it all. There's never going to
be any more death anymore. And the third
one is Gehenna. Now, this one is
interesting because it says right here,
"Hell is the place of the future
punishment called Gehenna or Gehenna of
fire."
This was originally the valley of Henam.
The valley of Henam south of Jerusalem
where the filth and dead animals of the
city were cast out and burned. a fit
symbol of the wicked and their future,
what's that word? In their future
destruction.
So, it's saying that the wicked are
going to be destroyed.
And how are they going to be destroyed?
In a place like this fiery burning dump
outside of the city walls of Jerusalem
called Hen. Now, it says right here at
the bottom, Gehenna of Hebrew origin,
valley of the son of Henam. Gehenna. A
valley of Jerusalem used figuratively.
Notice right there, this is blue letter
Bible. This is Strong's concordance
stuff. A valley of Jerusalem used
figuratively
as a name for the place or state of
everlasting punishment, hell. Now, you
might look at that word and say, look
right there, everlasting punishment. The
punishment is everlasting.
If the punishment is the second death,
which is an eternal death, that's
everlasting. You're never going to
change that. You're never going to come
back from that. It's an everlasting
punishment. If the punishment was
torture, and it said everlasting
punishment, then that would mean
everlasting torture. But it says that
the punishment is the second death, that
they're going to be destroyed. Remember
Jesus said, "Fear not him who can kill
the body but can't kill the soul, but
fear him who can destroy both body and
soul in hell." So the punishment that is
everlasting
is destruction and death. And it's an
everlasting death that you'll never come
back from. So I believe in everlasting
punishment in hell.
I just believe a lot differently than
what the majority of churches are
teaching. And I'm going to show you why.
This this presentation has like 60
slides, like 60 verses. So, that's a
lot. And anybody who right now who might
be like triggered or thinking, "Oh, no.
This guy, he's teaching heresy." Stick
with me because I need answers. I need
answers to 60 verses that tell me
something different than what I've been
taught my whole life and what I hear
being taught in churches right now. So,
please don't just bury your head in the
sand. Don't just ignorantly turn away
and say, "Oh, this guy's teaching lies."
Or whatever. Please help me understand
your point of view. I need to know what
these 60 verses mean that make it sound
like the like the wicked are destroyed
instead of given eternal life in a fiery
furnace.
And so here's the fourth
word that is translated into hell and
it's tarderus or in the Greek tartaroo.
And it says right here, the King James
translates Strongs G5020
in the following manner, cast down to
hell. It's only used once ever in the
Bible. Peter used this. Peter used the
word tartarus once. It's the only time
it's ever used in the Bible. And it says
cast down to hell. Now, here it's
talking about the um the context of it.
It says the name of the subterranean
region. Now, subterranean just means
underground.
I I I can believe that. I do believe
that everybody that I've ever went to a
funeral for, they put their body
underground. Now, they're six feet
under. They're subterranean.
Um, so the name of the subterranean
region, Doulful and dark, regarded by
the ancient Greeks, notice this,
regarded by the ancient Greeks as the
abode of the wicked dead, where they
suffer punishment for their evil deeds.
It answers to Gehenna of the Jews. So
remember I said that I said there was
two world views. The Jewish traditions
that were wrong and the pagan beliefs
which were wrong. And now this says that
this was an ancient Greek belief where
the wicked dead were punished. And it's
a it's kind of an equal counterpart to
what the Jews believe the traditional
the traditions of the Jews that believe
that in Gehenna.
And it says to thrust down to Tartarus
to hold captive in Tarderus. The verse
that was used was um was talking about
the angels that are going to be um in
everlasting chains and Tartarus and all
this stuff. Now, some of you are
probably already thinking this guy ain't
heard the rich man and Lazarus. Jesus
talked about the rich man and Lazarus
and Lazarus uh was up there in Abraham's
bosom and the rich man was burning in
torment. In this case, closed. There is
eternal torment in hell and the rich man
is down there right now burning forever.
I want to show you. Notice this says all
the parables of Jesus. It's searching
from sources all across the web. You can
open up any Bible that has a list of
parables of Jesus and you will find that
the rich man and Lazarus is listed in
these parables. Why? Because Jesus
always spoke in parables. What is a
parable? According to the definition,
it's a symbolic
fictitious
narrative of common life conveying a
moral. So Jesus knows that stories are
powerful. We teach kids the the boy who
cried wolf because it's a powerful story
that teaches children not to lie. We can
as parents, we can say all the time,
don't lie. You better not be lying.
Don't you dare lie. But where how's a
child actually learning from that? How's
a child actually learning what the
consequences of lying is? That's why
storytelling is so powerful. That's why
Jesus always told stories with a moral
with a lesson in it. And he told what
the Bible calls parables. And it says
it's a symbolic fictitious
narrative. Here it is again. And it
says, "Specially
an enigmatic enigmatical or fictitious
illustration."
Uh, the Strong's concordance says it's a
symbolic fictitious narrative.
But even then, people are like, "Oh,
don't you dare say that Jesus was was
telling a lie." I'm not saying he's
telling a lie. I'm saying that Jesus
taught powerful stories that had a moral
in them. If you take Jesus' parables
literally, then if you heard Jesus
sermon on the mount, you would walk away
from that saying, "Man, this guy was
teaching about how to uh build your
house on a rock and how to sew seeds.
Like, I don't know. I'm not a farmer.
I'm not a carpenter, so I didn't really
get much out of it." And you'd walk away
completely missing the sermon. You would
miss the sermon completely because
you're taking it literally. And you'd
think that Jesus was teaching you how to
build houses and plant crops. But Mark
4:34 says, "But without a parable spake
he not unto them." Jesus didn't even
speak unless he spoke in a parable. And
when they were alone, he expounded all
things to his disciples. So his parables
were not so straightforward. His
disciples would often be like, "Whoa,
Jesus, what were you talking about out
there?" I I especially remember the one
about the wheat and the and the tears.
He said, "Let them both grow together.
He's going to send out the reapers to
get the harvest. He's going to, you
know, uh bundle bundle up the the tears
first to burn them and all this stuff."
And and the disciples didn't even
understand it. They were like, "What
what was this about?" And he said,
"Well, the the the
wheat and the tears, this is the earth
and the the wicked and the righteous,
and the reapers are the angels." And he
had to explain the whole thing. Meaning
his parables aren't just
straightforward, right? They're not just
laid out like rich man Lazarus is so
obvious. He's burning in hell and all
that stuff. No, it's a parable just like
all this stuff is. It says it again.
Matthew 13:34. It says, "All these
things spake Jesus unto the multitude in
parables in fictitious stories with a
moral, and without a parable spake he
not unto them." This is case closed.
Everything that Jesus spoke to these
people in his sermons was a parable.
Why? Because Christ knows the power of
storytelling. And now Satan has hijack
hijacked that concept with movies. And
he's telling his parables, his stories,
right? But everything Jesus spoke was a
parable, including the rich man of
Lazarus, which we saw was in the list of
parables.
Matthew 13:35 says, um, why did he speak
in parables? That it might be fulfilled
which was spoken by the prophet, saying,
I will open my mouth in parables. I will
utter things which I have kept secret
from the foundation of the world. So
Jesus spoke in parables because it
fulfilled prophecy. So to take that
away, for anyone to say the rich man of
Lazarus was not a parable, you're you're
teaching false doctrine, then you are
denying the scriptures. You're denying
prophecy and you're denying the Bible.
You're denying the word of God at this
point. So, you cannot disagree that
Jesus was speaking a parable about the
rich man and Lazarus. Here we see that
this same terminology people always say,
"Well, the rich man of Lazarus was not a
parable because he used a proper name."
You show me the chapter and verse that
says, "By the way, Jesus couldn't use a
proper name in a parable. So, this is a
literal story. I have to see it from the
word of God. I cannot believe the words
and ideas of men that say Jesus can't
tell a story and use a name in the
story.
How how powerful are stories when they
don't even have a name? Have you ever
read a whole book and and it just says
person one, person two said to person
one? No. There's names in stories. It's
ridiculous the the leaps and bounds
these gymnastics we we do mental
gymnastics to try and believe that this
is not a parable when the Bible
literally tells us it's a parable. Um in
Luke 12:16 it openly tells you and he
spoke a parable. Now, this is not the
rich man of Lazarus, but this is a long
list of parables that Jesus was
speaking. And it says, "And he spake a
parable unto them, saying the ground of
a certain rich man." I highlighted that.
Notice a certain rich man. So, it's not
going to tell you every time Jesus spoke
another parable. Jesus spoke another
parable. Jesus spoke another parable. It
doesn't have to because it already told
you all these things Jesus spoke in
parables to the multitudes. So right
here it's it clearly plainly says that
he spoke a parable and he used this term
a certain rich man. Now Luke 16 is where
we see the rich man and Lazarus and it
says in this part it says and he said
unto his disciples there was a certain
rich man. Now Luke 16:19 this is exactly
the part. This is the rich man of
Lazarus parable right here. And it says,
"There was a certain rich man."
Just like Jesus said in all his
parables. Every time he started a
parable, there was a certain rich man.
There was a certain rich man. So all the
evidence is pointing to Jesus is telling
a parable about the rich man of Lazarus.
Now that might be triggering because
people are going to say, "Oh, you think
Jesus tells lies that that this isn't
real?" No, I think he tells stories and
he his audience of that time knew that
there was two world views that there was
the the Jews and the pagans and there
was these two world views and Jesus is
setting up the story and he says, "Oh,
there was Abraham's bosom and there was
Hades, a Greek mythological place,
Hades." He didn't have to say, "By the
way, guys, this is a fictitious story.
If I were to to preach a sermon and I
said, you know, one day there was a girl
named Alice and she tumbled into
Wonderland, I wouldn't have to stop and
say, "By the way, guys, this isn't real.
This is a fictitious story to teach a
moral, so just hang with me. But do not
believe that this is real." I wouldn't
have to. It's understood by the audience
because they understand, "Oh, I've heard
this before." So when Jesus says, "Oh,
there's this place called Hades and
there's Abraham's bosom," I want to ask
you,
um, when people died before Abraham
existed, there's a lot of people that
died before Abraham existed, where did
they go? Because Abraham didn't come
into the picture until way down here. So
these are just a handful of people that
died. But look, Adam, where did Adam go
when he died? Abraham didn't exist. He
didn't go to Abraham's bosom. What about
Seth? What about Enos? What about Jared?
Enoch. All these people, Methuselah,
Noah. Where did Noah go? Where did these
people go when they died if Abraham
didn't exist? It it's it's just
nonsense. It's it's it's a story.
Why? Why the story? I'm going to tell
you. Because
people used to believe that if you were
Jewish, you're going to heaven no matter
what. You are you're part of the
bloodline. You're the Jewish bloodline.
They believe that your bloodline would
make you go to heaven automatically.
Or that your wealth, if you were
wealthy, you were blessed by God. This
guy was both. The rich man, he was rich
and he was a Jew. So he thought, "I'm
going to heaven for sure." But guess who
went to heaven? It was Lazarus, the
poor, lowly beggar where the dogs were
licking his sores and all this stuff.
Jesus flipped the worldview on its head.
He said, "Look, I don't care if you're a
Jew. I don't care if you're rich. You're
still going to hell." That was what
Jesus was saying. It had nothing to do
with proving that there is a literal
place of torment. I I don't believe when
you watch the first video, what
happened? What really happens when you
die? It'll clearly tell you that the
dead are dead. The Bible says the dead
in Christ shall rise first. Why would
you call living people in heaven the
dead in Christ rising f? Where are they
rising from? We get these crazy ideas in
our mind that, oh, it's your spirit
that's up there in heaven. But then when
Jesus comes back, you got to go down to
your rotted body in a grave and put that
body back on just to be judged and put
on an immortal body and go, it doesn't
make sense. It doesn't line up with the
Bible. The Bible over and over and over
says that the dead do not praise the
Lord, that the dead know nothing, that
the dead are asleep over and over and
over. And it says that they're going to
rise when Christ returns, rise to the
judgment, the great white throne
judgment, which has not happened yet.
Now, this is a chart I found while
looking up the rich man of Lazarus. This
came from bible.ca. This is not my
chart. I do not believe this. But this
is what they say. They say the body
dies. Your spirit, which we know is the
breath is the breath of God which goes
back to God who gave it. When you die,
your your body goes to the dust of the
earth, but your spirit goes back to God
who gave it. Because your spirit is not
a conscious clone ghost of yourself, but
rather the energy life force that keeps
us alive. It's the breath of God. Um,
but here it says your body dies, your
spirit goes to either paradise or
tarderus. Now, where do we see the word
paradise in the story of the rich man of
Lazarus? I didn't see it. I saw
Abraham's bosom. But over and over when
I talk about this, people say, "No, no,
no. When you die, you don't go to
heaven. You actually go to this holding
chamber and you either go to Tarteus or,
you know, shield,
Hades, or paradise." They always say,
they say paradise is different than
heaven. Um, you know, when when Jesus
was on the on the cross, he told the
thief on the cross, you'll be in
paradise. But that wasn't the the final
destination. That wasn't heaven. That
was actually a different place. We got
to go to the Bible. I'm not going to
believe what a man says. For one, the
parable doesn't say paradise. The word
paradise is only listed three times in
the Bible. And all three times, it's
talking about heaven. And I'm going to
prove that to you, but I just want to
show you that these are the ideas that
people come up with that do not come
from the Bible at all. It's not in the
It's not in the parable. And paradise is
heaven. And I'm going to prove it to you
100%. It's not some holding chamber.
We've been taught that when you die,
you're actually going to go to shol as a
conscious being in a holding chamber
until Christ comes and judges you. This
is the doctrine of purgatory. Christians
are believing in purgatory, a Catholic
doctrine, because they're just twisting
the word of God. So, here's the three
times that the word paradise is listed
in the Bible. 2 Corinthians 12:4 and it
says, "How that he was caught up into
paradise and heard unspeakable words
which were which is not lawful for man
to utter." Notice it says, "Caught up to
paradise." We're taught that shiel is
under earth, right? A subterranean place
that's a holding chamber. So why would
he be caught up to paradise? You're not
going to be caught up to a place that's
down.
Luke 23:43 says, "And Jesus said unto
him, verily I say unto thee, today you
will be with me in paradise." Now this
is, remember, this is a English
translation. The punctuations were not
in the original Greek and Hebrew. There
was there was no punctuation in the
Greek and Hebrew. What Jesus is saying
right here is he's speaking in future
tense. He says, "I'm telling you today,
you will be with me in paradise." He's
not talking about some holding chamber.
He's not talking about somewhere else.
Abraham's bosom, which was a Jewish
tradition, a Jewish fable. He's talking
about heaven. Jesus is promising. Mark
my words today. You will be with me in
paradise. You will be with me in heaven.
And Revelation 2:7 tells us where
paradise is. He that hath an ear, let
him hear what the spirit says unto the
churches. To him that overcomes will I
give to eat of the tree of life. Pay
attention to that. the tree of life
which is in the midst of the paradise of
God. So where is the tree of life? In
the paradise of God. Now someone might
say, well it's the paradise of God. Now
is God's throne down in shiel in
Abraham's bosom. What this chart back
here said was that Abraham's bosom is
paradise and it's somewhere different
than heaven over here. But that's not
what I see in the Bible. And I have to
go with what the Bible says. And the
Bible says that paradise is up
somewhere. That Jesus promised the thief
on the cross that he will be with you in
paradise one day. And here it says that
the tree of life is in the midst of the
paradise of God. Now, where's the tree
of life? We I we got a scripture for
that, too. Where's the tree of life?
Revelation 22:2
or Revelation 22:1 and2 says, "And he
showed me a pure river of water of life,
clear as crystal, proceeding out of
where? The throne of God and of the
Lamb." So, we're talking about where
wherever this scene is is where the
throne of God is. In the midst of the
street of it, and on either side of the
river was the tree of life, which bare
12 manner of fruits, and yielded her
fruit every month, and the leaves of the
tree were for the healing of the
nations. So the tree of life is in the
same place. It's it's stretched out over
the river of life, which is coming out
of the throne of God.
This is talking about heaven clearly,
not talking about some subterranean
place called shiel or paradise or hades
or any of those words. Paradise is
without a doubt 100% in heaven in the
paradise of God where God's throne is
and where the tree of life is. That's
case closed. Case closed. There's no
such thing as this paradise. Abraham's
bosom is different than heaven. There's
no such thing as a holding chamber
before the judgment. There's death is
appointed unto men once to die and then
after this what? The judgment. Well,
when's the judgment coming? When the
great white throne judgment comes at the
end of the earth. And we're going to
show scriptures to show that. So, second
Peter 2:9 says, "The Lord knoweth how to
deliver the godly out of temptations and
to reserve the unjust unto when? the day
of judgment to be punished. So, there is
a day, a future day that's coming and
and the the wicked are reserved in the
grave. That's what we found out in the
first video reserved unto that day of
judgment. When is this day of judgment?
Says right here in John 12:48, it says,
"He that rejecteth me and receiveth not
my words hath one that judgeth him. The
word that I have spoken, the same shall
judge him when? in the last day. Not his
last day, not my last day when I die,
but in the last day, that's when the
judgment is. So, has the judgment happen
yet? No. So, when the verse says it's
appointing, it's appointed unto men once
to die. Then after this, the judgment,
there's a gap of time in there,
thousands of years possibly. What's
happening during that thousands of
years? Nothing. You are dead. Rotted
corpse. Your breath has gone back to
God. That's another verse. It says that
the body returns to the dust and the
spirit goes to God who gave it. He's up
in heaven, not in shield. And it's not a
conscious being that goes to heaven.
Matthew 13:40 through42 says, "As
therefore the tears are gathered and
burned in the fire, so shall it be in
the end of this world." So the judgment
where the wicked are burned happens in
the end of the world, not the day after
they die. They're not down there burning
somewhere. The Son of Man shall send
forth his angels, and they shall gather
out of his kingdom all things that
offend, so the wicked, and them which do
iniquity, and shall cast them into a
furnace of fire. There shall be wailing
and nashing of teeth. Now, these are the
types of terminology that people say,
"Look, that's hell, man. People are down
there. They're they're wailing and
they're nashing their teeth and they're
burning in a fiery furnace." I believe
all that. I do. We're going to look at
what that looks like, though.
John 5:28-29
says, "Marvel not at this, for the hour
is coming." So there's a it's not here
yet, but there's an hour coming in the
which all that are in the graves, where
they at, they're not in shield. They're
not in paradise or Abraham's bosom or or
Hades. They're in the graves. They shall
hear his voice and shall come forth.
Come forth from where? From the grave.
They that have done good unto the
resurrection of life. and they that have
done evil unto the resurrection of
damnation. Now, damnation does not mean
eternal torment.
Damnation just means punishment. It's
just another word. If you looked at this
in the in the uh Greek, you would find
out it just means punishment. So, some
are going to be resurrected to life.
Some are going to be resurrected to
punishment. What is that punishment?
We're told over and over that the
punishment is death. The wages of sin is
death, right? You're not How can you
live forever if you How can you live
forever in flaming torment if you do not
have the gift of everlasting life? Think
about that one. Daniel 12:1 and2 says,
"And at that time," when is that? This
is the future. This is the last day.
"And at that time, shall Michael stand
up, the great prince which standeth for
the children of thy people. And there
shall be a time of trouble such as never
was since there was a nation. Now this
is talking about the future tribulation.
We all know that that's coming, right?
The time of trouble like never has been
never been seen in this world. Even to
that same time and at that time at that
time only thy people shall be delivered.
Thy people shall be delivered. everyone
that shall be found written in the book
and many of them many of them that what
that sleep in the dust of the earth
they're not in shield awake alive
conscious they're asleep what happens
when you're asleep no consciousness
you're just dead asleep in the dust of
the earth shall what awake finally after
however long you've been dead in the
earth. When Christ returns, you're going
to awake. And it says, "Some to
everlasting life, some to everlasting
contempt."
Shame and contempt. Everlasting contempt
again is punishment. Contempt is like in
court, right? Contempt is your
punishment. Everlasting punishment. If
the wages of sin is death, if the
punishment is death, it's an everlasting
death that you'll never come back from.
You're not gonna wake up after the
second death.
James 1:15 says, "Then when the when,"
okay, so this is talking about sin and
it says, "Then when lust hath conceived,
it bringeth forth sin. And sin, when it
is finished, bringeth forth what?
Death." It doesn't say bringeth forth
immortality in the fiery pits of hell
for burning and for the endless ages. It
says that sin when it's conceived brings
forth death and it's going to be a
permanent death, an everlasting death,
an infinite death.
John 3:16, the most famous verse in the
world, says, "For God so loved the world
that he gave his only begotten son that
whosoever believeth in him should not
what? Perish, but have everlasting
life." So, we're seeing over and over
and over, we're seeing two different
choices.
God wants to give you the the gift of
everlasting life of immortality.
But if you don't receive the free gift
of everlasting life, the greatest gift
of all, then you get what? The opposite.
You get perish, second death, destroyed.
You get all these words, but it's not
everlasting life. You cannot have
immortality in flames of fire without
having everlasting life. They're two
opposite things. You either perish or
you have everlasting life. For the
wages, this is Romans 6:23, for the
wages of sin is death.
But the gift of God is eternal life
through Jesus Christ our Lord. The only
way only way you can live forever is if
you receive that free gift of God, which
is eternal life. Otherwise, you get the
wages. you get your wages of sin which
is death.
It's either death or life. That's it.
That this shouldn't be a complicated
thing, but tradition and paganism that
crept into the church has made this a
complicated thing. But in reality, if
you don't receive the gift of God, which
is everlasting life, you will perish.
You will not live forever. You will not
have eternal life. You will not exist
when your judgment comes. And we're
going to keep proving that 1 Corinthians
15:51-55
says, "Behold, I show you a mystery. We
shall not all sleep."
Why? Because some of us are going to
wake up. We shall not all sleep, but we
shall be changed in a moment, in the
twinkling of an eye. But when does that
happen? At the last trumpet. The last
trumpet. There are seven trumpets
sounded in the book of Revelation. Each
trumpet is sounded as a plague is being
poured upon the earth. So if we are
alive at that time, if we make it, there
is no pre-tribulation rapture. We got a
video on that. This this change that
happens happens at the last trumpet
after the plagues. Just like the just
like the Israelites in Egypt, they were
in Egypt during 10 plagues and then they
were pulled out and into the promised
land. It wasn't until after the plagues
that they got pulled out of that place
and entered into the promised land.
Right? It that is a a parallel for us.
So at the last trumpet, we shall wake up
out of our sleep and be changed for the
trumpet shall sound and the dead the
dead shall be raised incorruptible. It
doesn't say those who are alive in
heaven shall come back down into their
corpse and put on immortality. It
doesn't say that. It says, "The dead
shall be raised incorruptible
and we shall be changed for this
corruptible must put on incorruption."
We don't have incorruption right now. We
are corrupt. And this mortal must put on
immortality. We are not immortal. There
is a lie that's been taught in churches
for hundreds of years that you are
immortal. that when you die, you're
going to spend eternity somewhere. It's
either heaven or hell. Which is it,
buddy? And I hear it from Living Waters
with Ray Comfort. He says this stuff.
He's like, you when you die, you're
going to end up somewhere forever.
You're going to burn and burn and burn
or you're going to go to heaven. So,
choose you this day. Are you going to
say this prayer and and become a
Christian today and once saved always
saved? no matter what how you live,
you're always going to, you know, you're
going to be to go into heaven or the day
you die, you're going to burn forever
and ever and ever. But that's not what
it says. It says at the last trumpet, we
will put on immortality because we don't
have it.
So when this corruptible have put on
incorruption, and this mortal shall have
put on immortality, then at that moment
shall be brought to pass the saying that
is written, "Death is swallowed up in
victory. Oh death, where is thy sting?
Oh grave, where is thy victory? Now
notice it doesn't say, hey, if you're a
Christian, the day you die, you can
claim this promise. Oh death, where is
thy sting? Because it hasn't happened
yet. We haven't put on immortality until
Christ returns and resurrects the dead.
And then we're changed in a moment,
twinkle of an eye. And then we'll be
brought to pass the saying, oh death,
where is thy victory?
This is interesting stuff. I hope I hope
that this is sinking in. I hope this is
causing you to your gears to move and
you're you're starting to ask questions
and I I hope you're thinking of stuff
like, "Oh, I hope he addresses this or
what about this?" We need to be, you
know, the Bible says, "Come, let us
reason together." There's no reason to
argue. There's no reason to get mad at
each other. This is the word of God. All
I'm doing is reading the word of God.
And
if you believe that when you die, you
burn forever and ever and ever, or you
go straight to heaven or hell, I need
answers for these things. I have a lot
of verses that I'm showing you that I
need answers for. You can't just turn a
blind eye to this stuff. Genesis 3:22.
It says, "And the Lord God said, behold,
the man is become as one of us to know
good and evil." Why? Because he ate of
the tree of the knowledge of good and
evil. God didn't want us to have the
knowledge of evil. He was trying to
protect us, but we didn't believe him.
We didn't trust him. And we ate of that
tree of good and evil which caused
death. And it says, "And now, lest he
put forth his hand and take also of the
tree of life and eat and live forever."
So what God's saying is we can't allow
him to have access to the tree of life
anymore because he is now a sinner. He
actually has the knowledge of evil. And
we can't allow evil to live forever.
So why would the wicked be alive burning
forever and ever and ever? Because they
don't have right to the tree of life.
Because sin caused separation from the
tree of life. God in his perfect wisdom
said, "We cannot allow these beings now
who have the knowledge of evil to live
forever. So we must banish them from the
garden of Eden and they cannot have
right to the tree of life anymore. Not
until they live in this world of sin and
realize what the wages of sin leads to.
This is all a lesson. This whole life
that we're living, this this uh history
of earth that we're living is all a test
so that we can one day live in a perfect
paradise new earth and never be tempted
to go to sin again. To never be tempted
to sin again because we'll say, "I've
already been there. I've already lived
through that. I never want to go back. I
remember earth's history. I remember the
wars. I remember the pestilence. I
remember the famines. I remember the
addictions and the prostitution and all
that stuff. I remember the chaos of
where sin leads to. I never want to do
that again. I will never sin. Lord, your
law is perfect and holy and just, and
it's the perfect law of liberty, and I
choose by my free will to live according
to your law forever and ever and ever.
Amen. But we can't do that right now
because there's still a mystery. What if
God's keeping something from us? What if
he's trying to keep us from evolving?
What if he's keeping knowledge from us?
That's what all this is about. And it's
not just us. It's even the holy angels.
The holy angels in heaven still to this
day have free will. They could choose to
rebel against God if they want to. But
they are seeing, they're witnessing
firsthand, wow, this is what it this is
what happens when you don't obey God's
laws. This chaos.
That's why we're going through what
we're going through today. I hope that
makes sense. that Adam and Eve were
separated from the tree of life because
they they took of the fruit and they
now had their eyes open to evil, good
and evil.
Revelation 22:14 says, "Blessed are they
that do his commandments." Now, some
people say, "Oh, you know, we're not
judged according to what we do. Our
works are as filthy rags and all that
stuff." Yeah, you're not going to earn
your way to heaven. We've already
sinned. We've already sinned and we
don't deserve heaven. But thank God for
his mercy and grace. But now that he has
forgiven us and saved us. And it says,
"Blessed are they that do his
commandments." Why? That they may have
right to the tree of life. We that do
his commandments have right to the tree
of life and may enter in through the
gates into the city. I want to be a part
of that number. I want to be a part of
the number that choose to do God's
commandments. And there will be times
that I fail. I'm I'm a fallible human
being. But in those times, we have an
advocate with the father. And in those
times, we can come boldly before the
throne of grace and say, "Lord, I've
fallen. Please forgive me and give me
the strength to have victory over this
thing in my life. I don't want to do it
anymore. I don't want to be a dog
returning to his vomit over and over and
over again." The Bible says, "A
righteous man falls seven times and gets
back up." You don't fall and say, "Well,
I guess I'm I've already fell for it.
I'm gonna stay down here. I'm going to
wallow in it. No, you get back up. Every
day is a new day. Pick up your cross
daily. Die to the lust of the flesh
daily. That's how you do his
commandments. By living every day
according to his will and praying, God,
fill me with your Holy Spirit so that I
can have victory. So that I can have
victory over sin in my life. We can't do
it in our own strength. We cannot. It's
only by the strength of Christ and his
spirit.
So, here's here is a graphic to kind of
put the pieces together. Sin
caused what? Sin caused being banned
from the tree of life. So, we're all
sinners. We don't have right to the tree
of life clearly because we all die
causing death. We all know that this is
we sinned. We don't have right to the
tree of life and we will die. But one
day, those that keep the commandments of
God will have right to the tree of life
again.
For the wages of sin is death, but the
gift of God is eternal life through
Jesus Christ our Lord. Now ask yourself,
how can the wicked burn for eternity if
they don't have the gift of eternal life
or access to the tree of life? Ask
yourself that question. The wicked are
not going to put on immortality at the
last trumpet.
They did not receive the gift of God
which is eternal life and they will not
have right to the tree of life. So how
how can they burn forever and ever and
ever for the endless eternity ceaseless?
They cannot because they do not have
immortality. They do not have
everlasting life. They do not have right
to the tree of life so that they can
keep burning and burning and burning.
This is a lie from the pit of hell that
makes God look like a tyrannical
monster. And it's caused countless
god-hating atheists.
So many people that I debate with or
have discussions with, it always comes
back to the character of God. I'll never
serve a God that says, "If you do not
bow to me, I'm going to burn you forever
and ever and ever." That's not a God of
love. That's a God of fear and um threat
and intimidation.
That's not who God is. God is love. He's
not willing that any should perish, but
that all should come to repentance.
Psalms 37:10 and 20 says,
"For yet a little while, and the wicked
shall not be." Oh, wait a minute. The
wicked are not going to be anymore.
Yay, thou shalt diligently consider his
place, and it shall not be. But the
wicked shall perish. All right, they're
not they're not going to be. They're
going to perish. And the enemies of the
Lord shall be as the fat of lambs. They
shall consume into smoke. They shall
consume away.
These words shall not be perish into
smoke. Consume away. These are not
descriptions of people who are burning
forever and ever and ever with
immortality, with eternal life in the
flames of hell. This is saying that one
day the wicked are going to perish and
be no more.
Malachi 4:1 says,"For behold the day
cometh," it's not here yet, but one day
the day cometh that shall burn as an
oven, and all the proud, yay, and all
that do wickedly
shall be stubble.
What is stubble? When you burn your
grass out in the yard, stubble is like
your feet just it just pushes away. It
says shall be as stubble. The wicked
shall be as stubble, and the day that
cometh shall burn them up, saith the
Lord of hosts, and that it shall leave
them neither root nor branch. The wicked
are not going to exist. They're going to
be stubble. They're going to be burned
up. They're not going to be either root
nor branch. Malachi 4:3.
And ye shall tread down the wicked, for
they shall be ashes under the souls of
your feet in the day that I shall do
this, sayeth the Lord of hosts,
when the wicked are destroyed in the
lake of fire. You know where that
happens? We get this idea that hell is
in the core of the earth or somewhere
out in the cosmos somewhere and and
they're just going to keep burning and
burning and burning and burning. But we
are actually told that the wicked are
going to be destroyed by fire in a lake
of fire right here on the surface of the
earth. That's why it says that they're
they're going to be ashes under the
soles of our feet. That's why it says
they're going to be stubble because that
they're going to burn right here on the
surface of the earth. And if that's
true, how can they burn for eternity?
Because we're actually going to live on
this earth, a new perfect earth for all
eternity. So how are the wicked going to
be burning here for all eternity? We're
going to be walking the streets of gold
and say, "Oh, there's grandma burning
forever. Good to see you." It's it's
illogical. It doesn't make sense. It
doesn't go with the Bible. Revelation
21:8 says, "But the fearful and
unbelieving and the abominable
abominable and murderers and whoreongers
and sorcerers and idolattors and all
liars shall have their part in the lake
which burnth with fire and with
brimstone, which is what? The second
death." But notice it says they shall
have this is a future thing that's come
that's coming. It's going to happen
after the thousand years. That's when
the wicked are are judged after the
thousand years is finished. But it says
that their judgment is the second death.
The lake of fire is a permanent death
that you'll never come back from. It's
appointed unto men once to die. But some
are going to raise to everlasting life
and some are going to raise to a second
death. They get to die a second time and
they're never coming back from it. It's
permanent. It's everlasting. It's
eternal.
But it is a fulfilled time. It it is
it's death. It's not an ongoing life
that's being burned and burned and
burned for eternity. Revelation 20:9
says, "And they went up on the breadth
of the earth." Where are they at?
They're on the earth. Encompass the camp
of the saints about and the beloved
city. and fire came down from God out of
heaven and devoured them. Devoured
doesn't mean burn them for the ceaseless
ages. Devour means it consumes it. Like
if I devour some food, it's gone. You
don't see it anymore. Right? So I do
believe in fire. I do believe in a fiery
punishment for the wicked. I do believe
it's eternal and everlasting.
But it's going to devour them. It's
going to be a second death. That's a
permanent eternal death.
Second Peter 3:10 tells us, "But the day
of the Lord will con will come as a
thief in the night, in the which the
heavens shall pass away with a great
noise, and the elements shall melt with
fervent heat, and the earth also, and
the works that are therein shall be
burned up." So where is the destruction
of the wicked? Where is hell, if you
want to call it that? Where is the
punishment for the wicked happening?
It's happening right here on earth. And
it says that the elements are going to
melt with fervent heat and all the
works, all the evil works that are in
the earth shall be burned up, gone.
Because remember, we're going to set up
this perfect world right here. Christ is
going to renew it, restore it back to
back to Eden, and we're all going to get
to live right here on earth for
eternity. We think we're going to live
in heaven for eternity, but heaven is
coming down to earth and we're going to
live in the the original design where
Adam and Eve were put in the perfect
paradise. We're going to get to live
here for eternity. And there's not going
to be people burning forever and ever.
Revelation 20 13-15 says, "And the sea
gave up the dead which were in it. Death
and hell delivered up the dead which
were in them. This is the grave.
Remember hell is the grave which were in
them. And they were judged every man
according to their works. And death and
hell or the grave were cast into the
lake of fire. This is the second death.
Again, we're told the second death. And
whosoever was not found written in the
book of life was cast into the lake of
fire. Where is that lake of fire
happening? Right here on earth. Because
the wicked are going up on the breadth
of the earth at the after the thousand
years is finished. That's when they're
going to be judged. They're going to
come up on the breadth of the earth and
fire comes down from heaven and devours
them. And it happens right here on
earth.
Revelation 22:12 says, "And behold, I
come quickly, and my reward is with me
to give every man according to his works
to his work shall be." When Christ
returns, he's coming with his reward. So
why do we think that right at death, we
get our reward? Either heaven or hell.
That's what the majority of the
Christian world is teaching. When you
die, you get your reward. It might be a
good reward. It might be a bad reward,
but you're going to get it the second
you die. That's not what the Bible says.
He says, "I come quickly." Has Jesus
come back for the second coming? No.
I come quickly and my reward is with me
and I give it. He's going to give it to
every man according to his works,
whether good or or evil.
Matthew 16:27 says, "For the Son of Man
shall come in the glory of his father."
He will come. He's not He hasn't come
yet. He shall come in the glory of his
father with his angels and then he shall
reward every man according to his works.
Again, you're not going to be burning in
hell for thousands of years. Also,
I believe that God is a just and fair
God. Is it just and fair that um let's
say maybe a teenager who lived a short
life, maybe committed suicide or had a
drug overdose at 13 years old, he never
came to Christ and he dies. Now he's
burning in hell and a hundred years
later comes along Hitler and Hitler dies
and he burns in hell. When you look at
their punishment, this teen who died
without knowing Christ of a drug
overdose, his punishment was to burn for
a hundred years longer than Hitler. How
fair and just is that? It's not. And it
it's the same with, you know, grandma
died and she's in heaven for a hundred
years before I am. It's not like that.
There's coming a day that the reward is
given to us. The reward is not given to
us yet. The dead are dead. They will be
resurrected at the second coming at the
last trumpet and then he will give the
reward good or evil.
Matthew 10:28 says, "And fear," this is
Jesus talking, "and fear not them which
can kill the body, but are not able to
kill the soul, but rather fear him which
is able to destroy
both soul and body where in hell." So
he's saying this destruction of the
wicked or this this punishment coming
for the wicked which is translated to
hell. It's a destruction of the body and
soul destroy. He doesn't say but fear
him who will burn you forever and ever
and ever in hell. It doesn't say that.
John 3:16 doesn't say that. Romans
doesn't say that. Over and over and over
we're told there's two things here.
Death or life. Choose ye this day whom
you will serve.
Matthew 3:12 says, "Whose fan is in his
hand, and he will thoroughly purge his
floor and gather his wheat into the
garner, but he will burn up the chaff
with unquenchable fire." So, they're
going to burn up. But here's this word.
This might be tricky for some people.
Unquenchable fire. That sounds like
eternal fire. That sounds like it's
going to keep burning and burning and
burning. We see it again in Jeremiah
17:27.
But if ye will not hearken unto me to
hallow my Sabbath day, and not to bear a
burden, even entering in at the gates of
Jerusalem on the Sabbath day, then will
I kindle a fire in the gates thereof,
and it shall devour the places of
Jerusalem, and it shall not be quenched.
Now God is speaking and saying, "If you
disobey me, if you are lawless,
I will burn Jerusalem down with a fire
that can't be quenched." Does that mean
that Jerusalem would still be burning
and burning and burning till this day?
No. It's saying that no one's going to
be able to put out that fire when my
fiery punishment comes. No one is going
to be able to quench that fire. It will
turn that city to ashes with
unquenchable fire.
Mark 9:43-44
says, "And if thy hand offend thee, cut
it off. It is better for thee to enter
into life maimed than having two hands
and go into hell." Which this time it
was used gehenna. Remember we heard that
Gehenna was a figurative
imagery for what the destruction of the
wicked will be like that fiery dump
outside the city walls of Jerusalem into
the fire that never shall be quenched
where the worm dieth not and the fire is
not quenched. So here we see again that
the that the punishment for the wicked
is to go to some fiery place where the
worm dies not and the fire is not
quenched. First I want to I want you to
notice that this is figurative language.
Jesus is not recommending that you cut
your hand off. You're definitely not
going to enter into heaven maimed
because we're going to put have new
bodies, right? And Gehenna is this fiery
dump outside the walls of Jerusalem. So
this is all figurative of speech. He's
like, "Look, man, if you can't quit
sinning, it's better to like get rid of
that thing completely. Get rid of
whatever that temptation is so that you
can enter into life."
But when it says the worm dieth not and
the fire is not quenched, that all the
more illustrates a complete utter
destruction, annihilation. Because if
you are a rotting corpse, which was
often seen in Gehenna or in Henim and
the worms didn't never die.
They would consume a rotting corpse to
completely nothing bones.
And if the fire never went out, if man
could not quench the fire, then
everything in that pit would be ashes,
right? Because the fire couldn't be
quenched. The worms, if they don't die,
they consume it completely. If the fire
isn't quenched, it consumes it to ashes.
Here's an example of unquenchable fire.
These firemen can't put out this fire.
That house is destroyed, turned to
ashes. It was destroyed by unquenchable
fire.
It doesn't mean that the fire is
everlasting. It means it will consume
every bit of fuel without being put out
by man. Without being stopped in any
kind of way, it will consume the fuel
and it's unquenchable.
And the same with the undying worms. If
you have a rotting corpse and these
worms never die, they just keep eating.
There's not going to be anything left.
So a lot of times people will use these
verses, the unquenchable like
unquenchable fire and the worm dies not.
That means this eternal soul being
burned forever and ever and ever. No, it
it means the complete opposite. It means
there's not going to be anything left of
the wicked.
Ezekiel 33:11 says, "Say unto them, as I
live, sayeth the Lord God, I have no
pleasure in the death of the wicked, but
that the wicked turn from his way and
live. Turn ye, turn ye from your evil
ways, for why will ye die, oh house of
Israel?" God is pleading with people.
I'm trying to do the only thing I can do
to save you. I sent my son to die for
you in your place so that you can have
eternal life. All you have to do is
receive this gift and you can live
forever.
But if you don't, you're going to die.
He says, "I get no pleasure."
He He doesn't torment people forever and
ever and ever. And like, that's right.
Burn for that one lifetime of sin and
ignorance. Burn and burn and burn. I've
heard sermons like this. I've heard
people say that God laughs as he casts
people into hell and watches them burn
for endless ages.
That's not God. He is love.
And it says he takes no pleasure in the
death of the wicked. It doesn't say I
take no pleasure in the eternal torment
of the wicked. Jude 1:7 gives us an
example of the punishment of the wicked.
And it says, "Even as Sodom and
Gomorrah," these were wicked cities that
were destroyed by God, like judgments of
God came down. They were so wicked that
judgment came down. Think about how
wicked we are today. We're not seeing
fireballs come down and destroy cities
yet.
This cities, these cities were wicked.
Even as Sodom and Gomorrah and the
cities about them in like manner, giving
themselves over to fornication and going
after strange flesh are set forth as an
example,
suffering the vengeance of eternal fire.
Sodom and Gomorrah are an example of
what's going to happen to the wicked.
They're set forth as an example. And
what does it say that they suffered?
Sodom and Gomorrah suffered eternal
fire. Eternal fire. But Sodom and
Gomorrah is not burning right now. We're
not seeing smoke and fire to this day
from Sodom and Gomorrah. The the results
of the punishment were eternal. Sodom
Gomorrah will never return. They will
never be built up again because they
were destroyed by eternal fire. Now,
second Peter 2 verse 6 says, "And
turning the cities of Sodom and Gomorrah
into ashes."
They're not burning somewhere. They were
destroyed by eternal fire, turned to
ashes, condemned them with an overthrow,
making them an inample or example unto
those that after should live ungodly. So
that's the punishment. If you live
ungodly, you will be turned to ashes.
Just like Sodom and Gomorrah, turned to
ashes by eternal fire. It doesn't mean
that the fire burns forever and ever and
ever for all eternity. It doesn't.
Isaiah 47:14 says, "Behold, they shall
be as stubble. The fire shall burn them.
They shall not deliver themselves." This
is what's going to happen to the wicked.
They're going to be burned, turned to
stubble. They They cannot deliver
themselves from the power of the flame.
But guess what it says? There shall not
be a coal to warm at, nor a fire to sit
by.
That implies that the fire goes out.
The wicked are going to be destroyed by
fire. They will not be able to deliver
themselves from the flame. But there's
not going to be a coal to warmat, nor a
fire to sit by. That's because the fire
does go out. Once it finishes its job,
it will go out. And we will be on this
perfect world where the wicked were once
here, but they were burned out of
existence. And now we get to live in a
perfect world where their stubble ashes
under the soles of our feet. Revelation
14:11 says, "And the smoke of their
torment ascendeth up forever and ever,
and they have no rest day nor night, who
worship the beast in his image, and
whosoever receiveth the mark of his
name." A lot of people are going to have
this question. Well, I I get it. What
you're saying makes sense, but what
about Revelation? It says they're going
to burn forever and ever.
I mean, that's that's eternity, right?
Remember, we are reading an English
translation. We got to go to the Greek
and the Hebrew for some of this stuff to
make more sense of it. If you study this
out, you'll see that this word forever
in the Greek, it's eon, I think, or
maybe that's the Hebrew. Uh, I actually
didn't show you the Greek or the Hebrew,
but I challenge you. Look this up for
yourself, and you will see that this
term forever just means a span of time
until completion. It could literally be
any span of time. I'm going to show you
some examples. Jonah 2:2 says, "And
said, I cried by reason of mine
affliction unto the Lord, and he heard
me. Out of the belly of hell, cried I,
and thou heardest my voice." So Jonah
says he's in hell. But where is he
really? He's in a fish. But he thinks
he's going to die there. And so remember
the word hell is grave. He thinks this
fish is going to be his grave. And he's
crying out to the Lord from hell. The
translation that we are reading says
that Jonah was in hell for how long I
went down to the bottoms of the
mountains?
The earth with her bars were about me
forever.
Yet hast thou brought up my life from
corruption, oh Lord my God. So Jonah
just said that he was in hell forever.
But how long was Jonah in that belly of
the whale? For one, he wasn't in a fiery
place of torment. He thought this fish
was going to be his final resting place,
the grave. How long was forever in the
book of Jonah? Well, Matthew 20 or
Matthew 12:40 says, "For as Jonas was
three days and three nights in the
whale's belly." So Jonah was in the
belly of the whale for three days and
three nights, yet Jonas said it was
forever because it it this word forever
in the original Greek and and Hebrew
means any span of time until completion.
For Jonah, it was three days. He was
vomited out on earth and he did what God
told him to do. It was three days and
nights. Another example, Exodus 21:6
says, "Then his master shall bring him
unto the judges. He shall also bring him
to the door or under the door post, and
his master shall bore his ear through
with an all, and he shall serve him
forever."
So this is saying that a slave is going
to a human slave is going to serve his
human master for all eternity. No, he
can't because the master is going to die
and the slave is going to die. So
forever in this term means until one of
them die, he's not going to serve his
master once he dies. And once he dies,
he's not going to be able to serve his
master either, right? So forever does
not mean eternity unless the context is
eternal. And in this verse, the context
is something eternal. Revelation 11:15
says, "And the seventh angel angel
sounded, and there were great voices in
heaven, saying, the kingdoms of this
world are become the kingdoms of our
Lord." That's eternal, right? God's
kingdom is eternal. And of his Christ,
and he shall reign forever and ever. So,
we still have the same word forever and
ever. It's still the same in the Greek
and Hebrew, but the context is something
eternal. The context is God's kingdom,
which we know from other verses is
eternal. So when it says forever and
ever, it means forever and ever because
the span of time until completion never
ends. It's eternal. But when it comes to
the wicked, it ends. When it comes to
the belly of the whale, it ends. When it
comes to the slave servant's master, it
ends. So you can say forever and it
doesn't mean for eternity. It just means
until it's complete. So the wicked are
going to burn until there's nothing
left. Till they're ashes under the soles
of our feet. That's how long it's going
to be. So this verse back here that says
the smoke of their torment shall ascend
up forever and ever. It means, think of
this, every wicked person from Cain back
in Genesis, the first born person on
earth, every wicked person from Cain all
the way up until the second coming of
Christ. That's trillions. We don't even
have a number for how many people that
is are all going to be cast into a lake
of fire. There's going to be so much
smoke. It's as far as the eye can see.
You're It's forever and ever. I mean,
smoke just as far as you can see forever
and ever.
But eventually when they're all burned
up and turned to ashes, smoke goes out,
right? There's no more smoke. So that'll
be the end of the forever and ever. This
is when the wicked receive their
punishment. Revelation 20 7-10. And it
says, "And when the thousand years are
expired," this is a another heavy topic.
I know a lot of people think that we're
going to be in a perfect paradise with
Jesus on earth for a thousand years. But
remember, when Christ at the second
coming of Christ that we're waiting for,
he will not touch the ground. The dead
in Christ will rise first, and those who
are alive and remain will be caught up
to meet the Lord in the air. The wicked
will be consumed by the brightness of
his coming. And Satan will be bound to a
desolate earth for a thousand years.
He's going to be bound here for a
thousand years while we're in heaven
going through the books. It says the
books were open. We're going to get to
see every secret sin. We're going to get
to know why grandma didn't make it. Why
Pastor Bill didn't make it. We're going
to see every secret sin. Every time that
they had a chance to receive Christ and
they didn't, so that when we return with
Christ after a thousand years to judge
the wicked, Paul said, "Do you not know
that you will judge angels? that we are
going to judge the world after the
thousand years, we're going to come back
to earth and the wicked, the rest of the
dead. It says after then after the
thousand years were expired. Oh, I
actually I'm not showing that verse yet,
but another verse says after the
thousand years are finished, the rest of
the dead live not again until the
thousand years are finished. That's when
they're resurrected and that's when
they're going to get their judgment. But
Satan is going to deceive them and say,
"I just resurrected you. This being
that's coming down is our enemy and we
need to fight them and look at our army.
It's so much bigger. We need to go to
war with them and fight them." And
that's when Jesus has to bring fire from
God out of heaven to devour them.
Because at that moment, we see their
true colors that they're not even close
to repenting. They're actually fighting
against the son of God, Messiah. And so
they have to be destroyed because they
are unfit for eternal life. But here it
says, "And when the thousand years are
expired, Satan shall be loosed out of
his prison and shall go out and deceive
the nations which are in the four
quarters of the earth, Gog and Magog, to
gather them together to battle to battle
against Christ, the number of whom is
like the sand of the sea. And they went
up on the breadth of the earth." They're
on top of the earth. And compassed the
camp of the saints about in the beloved
city. And fire came down from God out of
heaven and devoured them.
And the devil that deceived them was
cast into the lake of fire on earth. I'm
going to show you another verse that
proves that. But there that lake of fire
is happening on earth.
Cast into the lake of fire and brimstone
where the beasts and the false prophet
are. And they shall be tormented day and
night forever and ever.
Like I said, it's going to be a large
amount of numbers, a huge number that we
don't even have a a name for. It's a
number like the sand of the sea. How
long will it take to judge each person?
How long will it take to judge? Let's
just say it's trillions, even though I
believe it's more than trillions. How
long would it take to judge trillions
into the lake of fire? You into the lake
of fire. You into the lake of fire. It's
going to be days and nights,
but eventually it will be done. There
will not be a coal to warm at, nor a
fire to sit by. And this word forever
will be complete. That span of time will
finally be complete. And then we'll be
in a new perfect earth forever and ever.
This is the fate of Satan.
Ezekiel 28:16-19, it describes Satan in
his unfallen state. How he fell and
what's going to happen to him. It says,
"By the multitude of thy merchandise,
they have filled the midst of thee with
violence, and thou hast sinned.
Therefore, I will cast thee as profane
out of the mountain of God, and I will
destroy thee." What's that word say? I
will destroy thee, oh covering cherub
from the midst of the stones of fire.
Thine heart was lifted up because of thy
beauty. Thou hast corrupted thy wisdom
by reason of thy brightness. I will cast
thee to the ground. I will lay thee
before kings. So where's it happening?
On earth. Cast thee to the ground in
front of kings. All can behold thee.
Thou hast defiled thy sanctuaries by the
multitude of thine iniquities, by the
iniquity of thy traffic. Therefore, I
will bring forth a fire from the midst
of thee. It shall devour thee. So
destroy, devour,
and I will bring thee to ashes.
Satan is going to be turned to ashes.
Where? upon the earth
in the sight of all them that behold
thee. All they that know thee among the
people shall be astonished at thee. Thou
shalt be a terror, and never shalt thou
be anymore.
When is the last time you heard a sermon
that Satan is going to be destroyed,
turned to ashes, be devoured, and be no
more?
We're actually told that he's going to
be like the Lord of hell and he's going
to be poking people. All of this is such
a satanic lie. Satan is the one who
caused all this mess. The first
rebellion in heaven, Satan caused it.
And churches are teaching, "Oh, he's not
going to get punished. He's actually
going to be torturing people forever and
ever and ever." That's the idea of hell.
But I want this to sink in. This right
here debunks all of it.
Hell is not somewhere in the core of the
earth. It's happening right here on top
of the earth. It says that Satan's going
to be turned to ashes on the earth and
he's never going to be anymore.
That eliminates the whole thing. The
nail in the coffin. The wicked will not
burn forever and ever and ever because
the first sinner, Satan, is going to be
turned to ashes upon the earth. And
that's good news. I'm so thankful that
God is not preserving wickedness,
preserving sin to burn forever and ever
and ever. Because picture this, we're in
heaven for a million years. And finally,
it comes to our mind, man, my my son, my
daughter has been burning ceaselessly
for a million years now. All because of
this God that I serve. He created that
torture chamber. He gave them
immortality to burn forever and ever and
ever. They only live to be 50 and
they've been burning for a million
years. How can I serve a god like that?
How can I serve a tyrannical monster
that would torture somebody? You know,
in a court of law, if somebody
murdered and raped and tortured somebody
on earth and that judge said, "Bam, I
sentence you to the rest of your life in
constant torture," we would say, "That's
cruel and unusual punishment. No way.
Don't do that."
And is is man more just than God? that
man has more of a conscience that you
should not, you know, endlessly torture
somebody just for one lifetime, let
alone an eternity.
God is more just than that. God is
loving. He's not willing that any should
perish, but that all should come to
repentance.
Just a few more verses, guys. I hope
that this is making you think.
Revelation 21:4 says, "And God shall
wipe away all tears from their eyes, and
there shall be what? No more death, no
more sorrow, no more crying, neither
shall there be any more pain. For the
former things have passed away. What are
the former things? Our loved ones. They
have passed away. There's no more pain.
There's no more crying. There's no more
sorrow. This verse right here would be a
complete lie if your family members are
burning forever and ever and ever and
ever.
But Jesus is not a liar. He's also not a
tormentor. He's not a monster.
He is love. And he's offering us the
gift of eternal life to live in a
perfect world forever and ever. And I
want to be there. And I want my family
and friends to be there. And I don't
want anyone to suffer the second eternal
death and to not live anymore. All of us
want to live forever. Nobody wants to
die. Nobody wants to cease to exist. We
live this short lifetime and we don't
want it to end because what is it all
for? What do we live 80 years for? To
just be gone and it's done. We all have
in us a desire to live forever and ever.
And if you don't, then God gives you
what you want. You don't want eternal
life, then you can have the wages of
sin, which is death.
Second Peter 3:13 says, "Nevertheless,
we according to his promise look for new
heavens and new earth, wherein dwell
righteousness."
I'm longing for that day. I I cannot
wait to live in a perfect world where we
are not facing this misery, this death,
the sorrow, the pain. Isaiah 65:17 says,
"For behold, I create new heavens and a
new earth, and the former shall not be
remembered,
nor come into mind." We're not even
going to remember the pain of this earth
because heaven is going to be so great.
The new earth is going to be so great
that after a few years, it's just like a
mother. A mother gives birth to their
child, that's a painful
procedure to go through. Sometimes it
takes hours of pain trying to push that
baby out. But guess what? When that baby
comes out, the joy that that mother has
seeing their baby's face and nurturing
that child and watching them grow up,
they can't even remember the pain. It
could be a year. It could be 10 years.
They're like, "You know what? I don't
even remember what that felt like
pushing that baby through the canal.
I can't even imagine the pain." But the
the mother, the she has that love. She's
got that joy. The pain is forgotten.
I pray that this was eye opening to you.
I pray that this was the truth setting
you free. That God is not a tyrannical
monster. That he is the embodiment of
love. He is love itself that he's not
willing that any should perish. He wants
all of us to come to repentance to be in
his perfect kingdom with him forever and
ever and ever. He created us for
friendship. He wants friends but he gave
us free will. And if we use our free
will for the lust and desires of the
things of this earth, then we're going
to receive the second death. You know,
I've heard some people say, "Look, hell
is eternal. If it's not, why would
anybody get saved?" That is not the
motivation for salvation. Fear,
fear-based conversion, bow or burn for
eternity. That's what some uh preachers
are doing. That's what some churches are
doing. They're saying, "Look, if you
don't accept Christ today, you will burn
forever and ever and ever and ever." No
sane person would ever want that.
But to choose God because the
alternative is so painful is not a
loving relationship with God. He wants
us to choose this day whom we will
serve. He wants us to fall in love with
him. He's knocking on the door of our
hearts. He's knocking on the door of
your heart. He's not forcing you. He's
not tricking you.
That's the tactics of the enemy.
Coercion and fear and deception.
God is love. And I cannot wait for him
to return. Jesus is coming soon. If you
don't believe it, watch the other videos
on our channel. You'll see it, man.
They're saying that aliens are coming.
Uh they're pushing for a one world
religion, a one world government. Jesus
is coming soon, and I want all of us to
be ready. Are you ready? If you like
this video, please give it a thumbs up.
It really helps this video get out into
the algorithm. Please share this with
with your family and friends because
this is a truth that will set you free.
This is a truth that will help you
understand God's character more than
ever before. It will dispel all the lies
that have been pushed out there in so
many churches. I want every church to
preach the truth of the Bible and the
Bible alone. I don't care what your
denomination says. We need to teach the
truth, the candid truth. I love you
guys. We cannot do this without you. If
you want to support this ministry, you
can do so by going to cantruth.org. We
got Cash App, Vinmozelle, PayPal. We are
a donationbased ministry and we truly
can't do this without you. I thank you
guys so much. All you guys who are out
there donating on Patreon, PayPal, we
see you. We try to get back to every one
of you and give you a personal thank
you. We cannot do this without you and
we thank you and we love you. If you
guys like cool t-shirts, we got some
cool t-shirts on our website,
candertruth.org.
I'm wearing one of them right now that
says, "Love is kind." Love is kind.
If you're new to this channel, please
click subscribe. Pleaseick click the
bell icon so you won't miss another
video. And we'll see you next time on
Candid Truth.